Okay, now for a little practical part, you can just watch this workshop.
We're not going to go into too much complexity, just nice and straightforward workshop to
round out this course.
We do have the files I'm using available to download.
If you did want to do this yourself, but there's nothing special about these files,
you could very easily mock something up yourself.
So no need to download the project files, but let's dig into a little workshop.
So I want to go through packaging our first game, changing a few project settings.
Let's just talk about packaging the game nice and easy to then close out our course.
So I'll just switch screens over to my project here.
I've just got the first person template downloaded.
I've just called my project game packaging, nothing special going on here.
I've just gone to games, I've clicked first person, you know, you could click third person,
you could look at any of the templates here and just call your project something applicable
like game packaging.
Again, you don't need to go through this step, but if you'd like to follow along,
we can go ahead and do that.
So we've got our game project and let's go to our project settings since we spent
a lot of time talking about our project settings.
So we'll just go here and, you know, we can change our project thumbnail if we wanted
to.
We can change our project name to, you know, let's call it my awesome game.
Yeah, because this is going to be an awesome game, you know, this is going to be an
awesome game.
We can do anything here, but let's not waste too much time.
Let's go to icon and you'll see that I've not got any icons downloaded for some of
these things.
You may have images, so that's okay, but essentially I just want to use the power
of this search bar to type icon.
And I want to go down to my windows platform here and I want to look at finding a game
icon for my game.
So I want to go to my desktop and I want to find my awesome game icon here.
And I just want to double click this.
Now this is an ICO file format.
So I've used the dimensions 256 by 256.
You don't need to do the same here.
But just so you know, like this needs to be an ICO file format, so you could, if you're
unsure how to do that, just Google online about how to make file formats in the ICO
file format.
And I've changed mine for windows.
You can update Linux or Mac or anything above, but we're just looking at windows
today.
So we've done our icon there.
Let's do our splash screen now.
And again, I'm looking at windows.
So if you're somewhere higher up the list with Linux on Mac, I just want to do windows.
So we've got two screens here that we can change.
We've got the editor splash and we've got the game splash.
Now these are both the same.
There's nothing too special about these.
You can see the dimensions as I hover over.
They are BMP files, but I think PNGs work equally as well.
But also the dimensions can change here.
So whereas the icon needed to be, you know, 256 by 256 or 128 by 128, the editor splash
screens can be any dimension and even the aspects can change.
I'm not sure if I can even just drag and drop.
Let's just see.
So I'll do editor splash.
No, I can't drag and drop.
So let's go back to my build process here and you'll see editor splash.
So we've got that there and let's just pull my game splash in here as well.
These are just some images from an epic fellowship, which I thought looked cool.
So these are my editor splash.
Now you'll see here that I've got two changes to source content has been made.
So I do want to go ahead and import these and then you'll see import done.
And what that has done is in my first person, if I press control and space bar and I got
to splash, I'll just untick level there.
You should see these two here.
So I'm just going to set them both, make sure I save that.
And these are now my splash screen.
So I can override those if I want to update my splash screens in here and they would
update in my project settings or you could just upload them directly in here.
That's also fine.
So yeah, let's go ahead and package our game.
We just want to go to platforms, windows, package projects.
Now I'll just create a desktop folder on my desktop called builds and you can create
my awesome game if you want, if I can spell awesome and it's like the folder path does
not exist.
Oh yeah, of course.
Yeah.
I don't want to put, I've already got a build folder there, so I don't need to type
anything there.
I'm just in the build select go.
And you know, with the magic of unreal engine packaging, this will go for, you know, depending
on your PC, it might be a few minutes.
It might be longer.
I've not got an overly powerful PC, but you know, it packages relatively quickly.
Now I've already packaged this project before, so it'll go quicker this time and
it's worth highlighting the kind of iterative cook nature of an unreal engine here.
So packaging is complete there.
That was super quick.
It didn't do that as quick the first time and that's because iterative cook is a thing.
So what happened there is it only cooked the new content that I had changed in this
game packaging project.
So if I had never cooked before, nothing is cooked and therefore unreal engine will
cook everything.
Whereas I have like in unreal engine, we have iterative cook.
So it iterates over previously cooked content and it only cooks the new content.
So, you know, just because your game, if you've made a game and it takes five hours
to package the first time you think, Oh my gosh, it's going to take five hours every time.
Not necessarily.
It depends on the frequency that you're cooking.
And if you cook again, you know, minutes later and not much has changed, the cooks,
the cook will be faster the next time because it's iterating over the cook.
So that's worth chatting about.
But anyway, let's look at our build here.
Now we have a windows folder because we deploy for windows.
You can see that I've got my game packaging project here, and you'll see that I've got
my pink icon because that's how I updated my pink icon.
So that's looking good.
If I double click this, it has my splash screen as you saw quickly there, and it's
got my awesome game.
I just need to allow access and there we go.
I've got my awesome game running and this is an executable.
So I now need to quit out of this game.
You know, I could have put a quit menu in there or anything like that, but you've seen
that we have a packaged game here now.
So that, as I go back to my PowerPoint here, we've added our own splash screen, changed
our icon.
You can do all these things yourself and you know, we've packaged our first game.
So does that, I mean, that's as straightforward as it can get.
Maybe you drank some coffee along the way or whatever your beverage of choice would
be.
But yeah, I mean, that's a nice little quick workshop on packaging our games.
So the only thing that I have left to say is just, I'm just excited to see the
games that people make in Unreal Engine.
It's always fun to see Unreal Engine games come online.
Really hope you have found this course valuable as an introduction to packaging and
publishing your games in Unreal and yeah, just thank you very much.
I hope you've got a lot of benefit out of it and we'll see you on the next course.